en el vídeo pasado establecimos una
integral definida para calcular el
volumen de este extraño sólido por el
método de los cascarones lo que voy a
hacer ahora es evaluar esta integral y
como hemos visto en vídeos anteriores
tenemos que empezar haciendo la
multiplicación de estos polinomios
empezaremos entonces desarrollando el
binomio al cuadrado esto es fácil esto
va a ser x cuadrada menos 6 x más 9 y
esto lo vamos a multiplicar por x menos
1 por x menos 1 que tenemos entonces
menos 1 por 9 es menos 9 menos 1 x menos
6 x es más 6x y menos 1 por x cuadrada
sería menos menos equis cuadrado vamos a
multiplicar por x ahora x por 99 x
positivo x x menos 6 x es menos 6 x
cuadrada y x x x cuadrada sería x cúbica
vamos a hacer la suma para obtener
entonces x cúbica menos 7 x cuadrada
15 x
-9 bien y ahora tenemos que multiplicar
por equis hemos hecho x menos 3 al
cuadrado por x menos 1 y tenemos que
multiplicar por x simplemente vamos
subir el lado del polinomio entonces
nuestra integral original se transforma
en vamos a poner que el volumen es igual
2 p la integral de 1 a 3 y que tenemos
vamos a multiplicar por x el polinomio
para que nos dé x cuarta
- 7 x cúbica más 15 x cuadrada menos 9 x
y por supuesto de equis iba a poner así
en este bonito a surgen bien vamos a
tomar entonces la anti derivada de toda
esta expresión esto va a ser igual a 2
pi por la anti derivada de esto del
integrando y esto lo vamos a evaluar
entre sí le vamos a restar lo que
resulte de evaluarlo en uno vayamos pues
al anti derivada la anti derivada de x a
la cuarta es x a la quinta sobre 5
- la anti derivada del 7x cúbica la
piedra de x cúbicas x 4a sobre 4 x 7
esto nos da menos 7 x 4a sobre 4 más
vamos a sumarle la anti derivada de 15 x
cuadrada la anti derivada de x cuadrada
es x cúbica sobre 3 al multiplicar la x
15 15 entre 3 es igual a 5 esto nos da
5x cúbica y finalmente se me están
acabando los colores la anti derivada de
menos 9 x que es simplemente menos 9 x
cuadrada sobre 2
esa es la anti derivada y si quieres
verificar lo puedes derivar y obtener
esto de aquí ya estamos listos entonces
para evaluar la anti derivada en los
límites superior e inferior esto es
igual a 2 pi que multiplica lo que
tenemos aquí evaluado en el límite
superior en 3 evaluando entonces cuando
x es igual a 3 tenemos 3 a la quinta
sobre 5 3 a la quinta es 243 quintos
déjame verificar tenemos que
3 al cubo es igual a 27 3 a la cuarta es
igual a 81 3 a la quinta va a ser 243
efectivamente esto va a ser igual a 243
quintos menos 7
por equis a la cuarta que es 81 7 por 81
déjame ver 7 por 8 56 567 deja de
verificarlo por aquí 81 por 7 7 por 17 7
por 8 56 si efectivamente 567 esto hacer
menos quinientos sesenta y siete cuartos
hay por lo que veo la aritmética se pone
un poco complicada pero la vamos a
librar vamos al siguiente término 5 x x
cúbica 5 x 3 al cubo 5 por 27 esto va a
ser 135 27 por 5 vamos a verificar los 5
x 7 35 y 35 por 210 313 135 esto está
bien si 135 entonces aquí tenemos más
135 y finalmente menos 9 por 99 por 9 81
menos 81 medios
bien esto es la anti derivada evaluado
en tres y vamos a restarle la anti
derivada evaluada en 1 vamos a restarle
la anti derivada en 1 entonces tenemos
que evaluado en 1 x a la quinta sobre 5
es un quinto menos menos voy a hacerlo
en el color adecuado menos siete cuartos
más
esto es simplemente 5 x 15 y menos menos
nueve medios
- 9 medios y que obtuvimos aquí una
operación con quebrados peliaguda pero
bueno vamos a hacerlo espero no
equivocarme hagamos esto entonces esto
va a ser igual a 2 pi y para hacer esta
suma and stones con un denominador un
mínimo común múltiplo que me parece que
es 5 4 y 2 el mínimo común múltiplo es
20 si voy a poner todo sobre 20 entonces
que tenemos primero 20 entre 5 es igual
a 4 243 por 4 a cuánto nos da 4 por 3
esto se lleva mos 14 por 4 16 y 117
llevamos 14 por 2 8 y 19
esto es 972 entonces tenemos 972 sobre
20 menos
- 577 cuartos en vigésimos esto va a ser
igual a 587 por 5 5 por 7 35 llevamos 35
por 633 33 llevamos 35 por 5 25 y 328
2.835 menos 2.835 vigésimos más vamos a
transformar la 135 en 20º 2 135 por 20
135 por 10 mil 350 por 22 mil 700 está
bien 2006 jones sobre 20 deja ver 1350
por 22 mil 700 y está bien está correcto
2000 sección sobre 20 luego menos 81
sobre 220 entre 2 es a 10 por 81
obtenemos menos deja de ponerlo con el
color adecuado menos 810 sobre 20
simplemente multiplique por diez arriba
y abajo
vamos ahora a hacer el resto menos un
quinto en vigésimos va a ser menos 4
vigésimos bien luego menos x menos más
aquí tenemos más 7 por 5 35 vigésimos
luego menos por más menos aquí tenemos
menos por más menos 100 sobre 20 y
finalmente tenemos que 9 medios en 20º
sería 9 por 10 90 90 sobre 20 para
vernos aquí ya me equivoqué con el signo
menos por menos es más si esto va a ser
menos por menos es más
tenemos que esto hacer más 90 sobre 20 a
ver déjame checar si es también estos
signos menos un quinto que es menos 4
vigésimos menos x menos más aquí lo
tenemos bien menos por más menos y
finalmente menos por menos más si ya lo
tenemos y ahora ya tenemos un problema
de sumas voy a sumar primero los
positivos ya sólo resta de la suma de
los negativos
vamos a hacerlo vamos a ponerlo por aquí
primero los post-it
y luego estaré los negativos
cuáles son los positivos tenemos qué 972
es uno de ellos
2700 35 y 90 vamos a hacer la suma voy a
ponerlo de manera vertical 2700 972
luego seguiría y quizá sea que la
calculadora para hacer esto no ya
hicimos tanto a mano que lo va a seguir
haciendo a mano ok
luego seguiría 90 y finalmente 35
hagamos esta suma que tenemos aquí 2 5 7
7 y 9 16 y 3 19 llevamos una lo hice
bien a ver 7 9 16 y 3 19 si llevamos 19
y una 10 17 llevamos 12 y 133 mil 797
este la parte positiva de la suma vamos
a hacer ahora la suma de los negativos
que tenemos aquí 2.835 810 4 y 100 vamos
a sumar estos negativos 2.835 luego
seguiría 8
los 10 luego tenemos 100 y finalmente 4
hacemos la suma 5 y 4
me da 9 luego 3 y 14 luego tenemos 8 y 8
16 y 117 llevamos 12 y 13 muy bien ahora
lo que tenemos que hacer es restar 3.749
de 3.797 y esta resta ya es fácil esto
nos va a dar 97 menos 49 esto nos da
igual a 48 esto es igual a 48 déjame
checar que no haya cometido un error
negativos menos 2.835 menos 810 menos
100 y menos 9 ok vamos a los positivos
2700 972 90 y 35 si está correcto y
3.787 menos 3.649 es igual a 48 entonces
el resultado final y merecemos una
fanfarria después de tanto trabajo va a
ser igual a 2 pi por 48 sobre 20
y 48 sobre 20 ya podemos simplificar lo
más
esto tiene cuarta en ambos casos
entonces tenemos que cuarta de 48 es 12
cuarta de 20 5 si estoy bien chispas
hemos hecho tanta aritmética que no
quiero caer en un error final si está
correcto entonces finalmente que tenemos
como resultado 12 por 2 pies 24 pi sobre
5 24
quintos y este es nuestro resultado
final hemos acabado